В селі Мужієво на Закарпатті розташоване
єдине в Україні родовище із підтвердженими запасами золота.
За оцінками геологів, цінного металу під цими землями
ховається понад п’ятдесят тонн.
Утім, вхід до цього родовища заріс непролазними хащами.
Вже більше восьми років тут нічого не видобувають.
Ніяк не розпочне роботи й новий власник – американська компанія Avellana Gold.
Рік тому вона придбала дозвіл на користування надрами
і проанонсувала понад сто мільйонів доларів інвестицій.
Зараз у нас труднощі
з двома державними службами.
нас на півроку зависли документи
без пояснень причини
і без відповідей на наші запити.
Прихід Avellana Gold на ринок
був сприйнятий від початку неоднозначно.
Адже остання компанія, яка мала право на видобуток золота,
належала оточенню тодішнього міністра внутрішніх справ Віталія Захарченка.
Та після революції  міністра оголосили в розшук,
а ось його бізнес-партнера - ні.
Валерій Бредихин міг спокійно продати фірму американському бізнесмену.
До з’ясування обставин на компанію навіть наклали арешт.
На даний момент арешт знято, нас визнали доброчинним інвестором,
будь ласка,ви можете подивитися,
им ми займалися і чим займались усі члени команди.
Та тепер виникають труднощі з отриманням ліцензій.
DW хотіла запитати у нового очільника Держгеонадр,
якого, між іншим, поза конкурсом призначив у травні Кабмін,
чому так та які умови співпраці з іноземною компанією.
Утім, нам відповіли лише відпискою –
мовляв, усі переговори з Avellana Gold
відбувались за попереднього керівництва Держслужби
і на разі ніякі консультації з цього питання не проводяться.
Економіст Олег Пензин за історією з американськими інвесторами
слідкує з інтересом.
Адже і попередні іноземні інвестори
зазнавали в Україні прикрих поразок.
Наприклад, австралійці залишили 1 мільйон доларів,
канадці - 65 мільйонів.
Та врешті, через постійні перевірки, ненадання ліцензій
або віджимання бізнесу «золотошукачами» при владі, пішли з України.
У тому ж, що українське золото видобуватимуть іноземці,
проблем не вбачає.
добуте золото все одно буде продаватись за українськими законами
і першочергово будуть учасником викупу
по фіксованим цінам національний банк України,
золотовалютні резерви, тому я не бачу в цьому нічого поганого в дійсності.
Чому б і ні.
Чекають інвестора і у самому селі.
У селищній раді, де поруч з українським висить і угорський прапор,
а час на годинниках стоїть також не київський,
сподіваються на те, що бізнес зупинить відтік молоді з регіону.
Добре було би для людей,
бо багато б робочих місць було.
Єдине, про що непокояться мешканці,
це про екологічність нового проекту.
Та чи не погіршать нові технології видобутку життя в селі.
Адже за відсутності роботи селяни почали розвивати зелений туризм.